R
MESSAGE THAT WAS QUICKLY
DELETED.
>> JENNIFER, THANK YOU.
MAKE NO MISTAKE: OUTGUNNED,
OUTMANNED, THE UKRAINIAN AND
UKRAINIAN PEOPLE, THEY ARE
HEROICALLY FIGHTING FOR THEIR
COUNTRY AND FOR THEIR LIVES.
IF THEY ARE USING OUTDATED
SOVIET ERA FIGHTERS, UKRAINIAN
PILOTS -- THEY ARE GUNNING DOWN
MODERN RUSSIAN PLANES.
ON THE GROUND, UKRAINIAN
SOLDIERS ARE TAKING OUT DOZENS
OF RUSSIAN TANKS WITH
AMERICAN-MADE JAVELIN ROCKETS.
MEANWHILE, REGULAR CITIZENS, MEN
AND WOMEN ALL OVER UKRAINE ARE
PICKING UP GUNS, ANYTHING THEY
CAN GET THEIR HANDS ON: MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS -- THEY ARE PREPARING
FOR URBAN WAR, SOME KIND OF
INSURGENCY.
ON A REMOTE UKRAINIAN ISLAND IN
THE BLACK SEA, 13 UKRAINIAN
BORDER GUARDS CAME UNDER ATTACK
FROM A RUSSIAN WARSHIP.
INSTEAD OF SURRENDERING, THEY
TOLD HER RUSSIANS THAT THEY CAN
GO F THEMSELVES, AND FOUGHT TO
THE BITTER END.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>>
[SPEAKING NON-ENGLISH LANGUAGE]
>> Hannity: EVERYONE OF THOSE
PEOPLE LOST THEIR LIVES LAST THT
NIGHT STANDING UP FOR THEIR
COUNTRY IN THE FACE OF CERTAIN
DEATH, DID NOT BACK DOWN.
JOE BIDEN WILL NOT STAND UP TO
CLIMATE CHANGE ALARMISTS IN HIS
OWN PARTY AND EXPAND AMERICAN
OIL AND GAS EXPLORATION,
DRILLING.
ALL THE THINGS THAT WE COULD DO
TO EASE THE PRESSURE ON OUR NATO
ALLIES IN WESTERN EUROPEAN
PARTNERS, AND LITERALLY REMOVE
THE U.S. FROM OUR DEPENDENCE
THAT HE BROUGHT UPON THIS
COUNTRY ON FOREIGN ENERGY,
INCLUDING THE MILLIONS OF
BARRELS OF OIL THAT JOE BIDEN,
AND 2021, IMPORTED FROM RUSSIA:
232 MILLION, TO BE EXACT.
JOE BIDEN HAS CREATED A 40 YEAR
RECORD HIGH IN INFLATION THAT'S
HURTING EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN,
ALL BECAUSE OF HIS FAILED
ECONOMIC AND ENERGY POLICIES.
THESE SAME POLICIES ARTIFICIALLY
REDUCE THE WORLD SUPPLY OF
ENERGY, THE LIFEBLOOD OF THE
WORLD'S ECONOMY.
IT'S WEAKENED OUR NATIONAL
SECURITY IN WAYS TOO PROFOUND TO
CALCULATE AT THIS TIME, AND ARE
NOW RELYING ON RUSSIA, OPEC,
SAUDI ARABIA FOR THE LIFEBLOOD
OF OUR ECONOMY.
HE INHERITED ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, AMERICA AS A NET
EXPORTER OF ENERGY.
JOE'S POLICIES HAVE HELPED CHASE
OUR EUROPEAN FRIENDS AND ALLIES
AND NATO PARTNERS INTO THE ARMS
OF VLADIMIR PUTIN.
WE SHOULD BE SUPPLYING THEM WITH
THEIR ENERGY NEEDS, NOT RUSSIA,
NOT VITAMIN PUTIN.
THEY ARE MAKING HIM RICH.
BY THE WAY, JOE WILL NOT STAND
UP TO OUR ALLIES IN EUROPE.
HE'S BEING ROLLED BY GERMANY,
ITALY, BELGIUM.
THEY DON'T WANT TO REMOVE RUSSIA
FROM THE ALL-POWERFUL SWISS
BANKING SYSTEM, BECAUSE THEY ARE
THINKING ABOUT THEIR SELFISH
ECONOMIES.
MAYBE THEIR COUNTRY IS GOING TO
BE NEXT.
MAYBE, THEY ARE ON THE LIST OF
COUNTRIES THAT WILL BE INVADED.
RUSSIAN OIL COULD BE CUT OFF.
AS A MATTER OF FACT, ACCORDING
TO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION, THE
SANCTIONS ARE SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO KEEP RUSSIAN OIL
FLOWING.
THAT WOULD RENDER EVERY OTHER
SANCTION MEANINGLESS.
IT WOULD NEGATE EVERY OTHER
SANCTION.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO ALLOW RUSSIA
TO STAY IN THE OIL AND GAS AND
ENERGY BUSINESS, THAT'S WHERE
PUTIN IS GETTING ALL THE MONEY
TO FUND HIS TERRITORIAL
AMBITIONS.
>> WHAT I AM SAYING IS THAT OUR
MEASURES WERE NOT DESIGNED TO
DISRUPT THE CURRENT FLOW OF
ENERGY FROM RUSSIA TO THE WORLD.
>> THIS IS THE SINGLE MOST
IMPORTANT SANCTION JOE SHOULD'VE
PUT ON RUSSIA.
IT'S THE ONLY ONE THAT MEANS
ANYTHING.
JOE IS ALLOWING PUTIN TO GET
EVEN RICHER AS OIL AND GAS IS
THE LIFEBLOOD -- HALF OF
RUSSIA'S ECONOMY.
WITHOUT THE OIL, WITHOUT THE
GAS, WITHOUT THE SANCTIONS ON
OIL AND GAS, GUESS WHAT?
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO STOP OR
DETER FLATTERY PUT IN.
YOU ARE ONLY AIDING AND ABETTING
HIM.
LISTEN TO THIS QUESTION FROM OUR
OWN PETER DOOCY.
>> WHAT IS THAT DONE THROUGHOUT
THIS CRISIS THAT HAS WORKED?
>> Secretary Psaki: IN WHAT
CAPACITY?
REPORT BACK THE PRESIDENT TALKED
TO PUT IN, PUT SANCTIONS IN
PLACE, NOW, SAID THEY ARE GOING
TO TAKE 30 DAYS -- OR ABOUT A
MONTH.
DO YOU THINK THE PEOPLE IN
UKRAINE HAVE A MONTH?
>> Secretary Psaki: LET ME
TAKE A STEP BACK AND EXPLAIN HOW
DIPLOMACY WORKS AND HOW THEY
APPROACH FROM THE UNITED STATES
HAS WORKED.
WITH THE PRESIDENT HAS DONE HAS
BUILT A GLOBAL COALITION TO
STAND UP IN THE FACE OF
PRESIDENT PUTIN.
>> Hannity: SANCTIONS, BUT NOT
THE ONE THAT WOULD BE MOST
MEANINGFUL, THAT WOULD IMPACT
RUSSIA THE MOST AND TO BE THE
MOST EFFECTIVE.
IN OTHER WORDS, JOE BIDEN, HIS
ADMINISTRATION, THEY ARE DOING
NOTHING, WHICH IS, SADLY FOR
THEM, POWER FOR THE COURSE.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER LAST MAY WHEN
HE DID NOTHING AFTER -- THE
COLONIAL PIPELINE SYSTEM THAT
CAUSED GAS SHORTAGES UP AND DOWN
THE EAST COAST OF AMERICA.
IN JUNE, WHEN BIDEN DID NOTHING
AFTER PUTIN STARTED SURROUNDING
UKRAINE WITH TENS OF THOUSANDS
OF TROOPS AND MILITARY
EQUIPMENT.
IN JULY, WHEN BIDEN DID NOTHING
AFTER PUTIN DELIVERED A DERANGED
MESSAGE ABOUT RESTORING THE
SOVIET UNIONS FORMER GLORY,
LAYING OUT HIS PLANS FOR THE
FUTURE, AND ON MONDAY, WHEN
BIDEN DID NOTHING WHEN PUTIN
TOLD THE WORLD THAT HE WAS GOING
TO TAKE UKRAINE BY FORCE.
BY THE WAY, I WANT TO BE CLEAR:
I AM NOT SUGGESTING THAT WE HAVE
A SHOOTING WAR WITH RUSSIA.
FOR CRYING OUT LOUD, COULD WE AT
LEAST PUT THE SANCTION THAT
MATTERS THE MOST IN PLACE, AND
AT LEAST STOP RUSSIA FROM
SELLING THEIR OIL AND
ACCUMULATING EVEN MORE MONEY AND
WEALTH THAT'S FUNDING
TERRITORIAL AMBITIONS LIKE
UKRAINE?
COULD WE MAYBE SANCTION RUSSIA'S
ENERGY PRODUCTION?
THAT'S THE ONE SANCTION THAT
WOULD BE MEANINGFUL.
AT LEAST WE COULD START
PRODUCING MORE OIL AND GAS AT
HOME, AND THEN AMERICA COULD GET
RICH.
IT WOULD BE GREAT FOR NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WOULDN'T HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT
PUTIN, THE MIDDLE EAST.
WE CREATE HIGH PAYING CAREER
JOBS IN AMERICA, AND AT THE SAME
TIME, WE WOULD BE ENERGY
INDEPENDENT AND BE ABLE TO HELP
OUT OUR NATO ALLIES AND WESTERN
EUROPEAN COUNTRIES THAT
DESPERATELY NEED OIL AND ENERGY
FOR THEIR ECONOMIES.
THERE'S NOT A CHANCE.
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION THAT'S NOT A
TOTAL IDIOT AT THIS POINT?
NOW WITH KEVIN CIRCLE BY RUSSIAN
TROOPS, JOE BIDEN IS HEADED FOR
A LONG WEEK IN DELAWARE.
THAT'S GREAT.
BIDEN FEELING DOMINIC LEAVING
THE WHITE HOUSE, TAKING OFF.
HE NEEDS HIS REST AND
RELAXATION.
MY GUESS IS BY NOW, HE HAS HAD
HIS ICE CREAM AND HAS TAKEN A
LONG NIGHT'S SLEEP.
IT'S BEEN A TOUGH WEEK FOR JOE.
WHAT A DISGRACE.
DURING THE CAMPAIGN, BIDEN ONCE
PROCLAIMED THAT A FIFTH YEAR OF
DONALD TRUMP AS PRESIDENT WOULD
SPELL DISASTER FOR UKRAINE.
AS IT TURNS OUT, ONE YEAR UNDER
BIDEN WAS FAR WORSE.
>> TO STATE THE OBVIOUS
>> President Biden: TO STATE
THE OBVIOUS, WE HAVE TO DEFEAT
DONALD TRUMP.
[APPLAUSE]
WE CANNOT GET A DAMN THING DONE
UNLESS HE IS DEFEATED.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF WORK
TO MAKE UP FOR ALL THE DAMAGE
HE'S DONE INTERNATIONALLY AND
NATIONALLY.
HIS NETWORK OF THUGS AND
COCONSPIRATORS ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO TRY TO UNDERMINE OUR
DEMOCRACY, IN THE MEANTIME.
IMAGINE WHAT HE CAN DO IN
ANOTHER YEAR.
IMAGINE WHAT CAN HAPPEN IN
UKRAINE.
>> Hannity: JOE DIDN'T WANT
THAT.
THAT WOULD BE BAD FOR THE FAMILY
SYNDICATE.
REMEMBER, HUNTER -- JOE BIDEN
LEVERAGED $1 BILLION TAXPAYERS,
AND SAID "YOU'RE NOT GETTING
THAT UNLESS YOU FIRE THIS
INVESTIGATOR WHO IS
INVESTIGATING HUNTER, WHO IS
MAKING MILLIONS, WHO ADMITTED ON
ABC THAT HE HAD NO EXPERIENCE IN
ENERGY, OIL, GAS, OR UKRAINE."
WHY DO YOU THINK THEY ARE PAYING
YOU MILLIONS, HUNTER?
"I DON'T KNOW."
COULD IT BE BECAUSE YOUR DAD IS
THE VICE PRESIDENT IN CHARGE OF
UKRAINIAN POLICY?
THAT WAS THE QUID PRO QUO AT THE
MEDIA MOB IGNORED.
BACK TO THE ISSUES OF TODAY.
BIDEN NEEDS TO TURN AROUND, GET
BACK TO THE WHITE HOUSE, OR IF
HE CAN'T AND IS NOT UP TO THE
JOB, WHICH EVERYDAY AMERICANS
ARE BEGINNING TO SEE HE'S NOT UP
TO THE JOB -- MAY BE, IT'S TIME
TO STEP ASIDE, LET SOMEONE MORE
CAPABLE, MORE COGNITIVELY ALERT
TAKE THE REINS.
THIS HAS THE POTENTIAL TO SPIRAL
OUT OF CONTROL FAST WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT AN EVIL, MANIACAL
DICTATOR WITH TERRITORIAL
AMBITIONS THAT PROBABLY GO WELL
BEYOND, AND EVEN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ADMITTING,
WELL BEYOND UKRAINE READ IT'S
PAST TIME FOR DEVASTATING
SANCTIONS ON RUSSIAN OIL AND
GAS.
IF YOU ARE NOT WILLING TO TAKE
THAT ONE HARD STEP, THAT MEANS
YOU ARE NOT WILLING TO PUT THE
PAIN ON PUTIN THAT HE DESERVES.
WITHOUT THAT PAIN, WHAT'S GOING
TO STOP HIM FROM INVADING
NEIGHBORING POLAND, OR THE
BALTIC STATES?
OKAY, WELL IF AN ATTACK ON ONE
IS AN ATTACK ON ALL, OKAY,
THAT'S THE NATO AGREEMENT.
IS THAT GOING TO WORK?
IF THAT HAPPENS, WILL NATO WILL
GO TO WAR WITH RUSSIA?
IT'S EITHER GOING TO BE WORLD
WAR III OR WE ARE GOING TO
ABANDON OUR ALLIES, ABANDON
NATO.
NATO WILL BE EXPOSED AS A PAPER
TIGER.
DON'T FORGET 1994 DURING THE
BUDAPEST AGREEMENTS.
THAT'S WHEN UKRAINE AGREED TO
GIVE UP THEIR NUCLEAR ARSENAL
THREE YEARS EARLIER IN 1991.
THEY SECEDED FROM THE FORMER
SOVIET UNION.
IT WAS THE THIRD LARGEST HOLDER
OF NUCLEAR WEAPONS IN THE WORLD,
AND THEY WERE HOLDING ONTO
THOSE.
AS PART OF THIS AGREEMENT, AND
IN EXCHANGE, THEY HANDED THOSE
WEAPONS BACK TO RUSSIA TO BE
DESTROYED.
RUSSIA PROMISED THEY WOULD NEVER
ATTACK UKRAINE, AND THAT THE
U.S. AND U.K. WOULD BACK THEM
UP, MEANING THE UKRAINIANS.
WHAT'S THE LESSON?
NUMBER ONE, DON'T GIVE UP
NUCLEAR WEAPONS IF YOU HAVE
THEM.
NUMBER TWO, UNDER PUTIN, RUSSIA
DOES NOT GIVE A FLYING RIP ABOUT
ITS WORD, AGREEMENTS, ALLIANCES,
NOTHING.
THE ONLY THING PUTIN WILL
RESPOND TO HIS STRENGTH.
DONALD TRUMP UNDERSTOOD THIS.
BY THE WAY, NOW EUROPE AND THE
U.S. NEED TO IMMEDIATELY TAKE
ACTION AGAINST RUSSIA'S OIL AND
GA